before we started the show i was talking
about the five g's with my guys can we
go through the five g's
of course i love the 5gs
i know i know take it away
i'm dave rubin and joining me today is
author of the world famous book rich dad
poor dad and author of the brand new
book capitalist manifesto how
entrepreneurs can save capitalism robert
kirasaki welcome to the reuben report
well thank you honor to be on your
program you're doing a great job thank
you oh i appreciate that well i am glad
to have you on because in my last book i
did one
chapter on capitalism to try to save
capitalism but your whole life has been
about trying to save capitalism so
before we get into capitalism itself
give me a little bit of your bio for the
people that maybe have not read it
because it's quite extraordinary and
pretty much explains exactly why you
care about the things that you write
about right it's more than capitalism
david i'm fighting for our freedom
and there's a very there's a fine line
you know between that and capitalism
but my background is i'm fourth
generation japanese american
and the reason i say that is
during the vietnam war i was a us marine
and some people think you fought for the
japanese marine corps
i always thought that was funny
i've been accused of being a white
supremist
because i support freedom i support
capitalism
i said i looked in the mirror i said
well i'm still not white
you know it's just um
it's amazed it's amazing how little
people know
it shocks me so anyway my background is
a fourth generation japanese american
was raised in hawaii
and i had the misfortune of good fortune
to go to a rich kids school a rich white
kid school in a little town called hilo
hawaii
so on one side of the street i mean
exactly opposite was hilo union school
and hilo union school was for all the
minorities the japanese the chinese the
filipino the portuguese and all this
and directly across the street
was riverside school for the rich kids
and i didn't just my father was head of
education poor dead
and he didn't he didn't gyrate
manipulate anything i just happened to
fall into the district with the rich
kids school
but that i was nine years old i'm going
well how come some people are rich
and why are some people poor
and as you know david one of the biggest
problems we have today is this gap
between rich and poor
it sets up revolution
and i don't think that's a mistake
so i might go to this rich kids school
and i asked the teachers well how do i
get rich
well she said you stay in school
i said my poor dad stayed in school he's
still poor
you know how kids are they go que pasa
what's happening here yeah
so that's how the story of rich dad poor
dad started
but the real test of the thing was that
was up to that movie caddyshack
you know years ago chevy chase and all
those characters seen it roughly four
thousand times
but that's the classic story i've rich
and poor you know so
my attend i take up the game of golf
and i have to hitchhike to the country
club
but i had to sit in the caddyshack
and my classmates are in the country
club
and i keep asking myself again you know
que pasa
how come some people are rich
and some people are poor
and it kind of became my lifelong quest
and uh
question on that i did go to military
school i mean i was a horrible student
but i got congressional nominations the
naval academy
and u.s merch marine academy in new york
i took march green academy
and in 1965 when i went there it's a
purely military is one of the five
federal academies of the air force army
navy coast guard and um anyway
this is the book they had to read
so while my peers going to traditional
snowflake you
are studying uh keynes and adam smith
and
my economics teacher at the academy had
us read marx hitler mao style
lennon
so at 18 years old dave i'm effed up
you know
holy mackerel
and that's when the kind of light scored
i'm 18 years old military school and
being yelled at screamed at
and i realized that most of my friends
are communists
but they don't know it and not say
they're bad people
that's like can you be
can you be a hindu can you be christian
can you be muslim can be jewish
economics is basically a religion
that's all it is
so the moment my my my economics teacher
at the military school is teaching me
this stuff i'm going most school
teachers are marxists
you know and that's kind of when the
lights kept going on
so i graduated in 1969 my background is
oil so i do know what i'm talking about
when it comes to oil
so when that sucker bite and cut off the
keystone xl pipeline i said that man's a
communist because i know what he was up
to you know i mean i'm an oil guy i sell
for standard oil my first protocol was
valdez alaska the alaska pipeline 1969
i'm going
holy mackerel
that i could see communism seeping into
our country plus i'm so old columbia
university was one of the first ones
that had the
riots
and they're in the 60s and the ryerson
spread through all the colleges
throughout the united states
so when you read this book here you'll
find out
that in 1930
communism came into america from the
frankfurt school
and they embedded themselves in columbia
university teachers college
and so that was the 1930s and in as a
student as a
as a baby boomer you know i go to
vietnam twice 65 66 and 72 i fly for the
us marine corps at the japanese marine
corps
noted i will i will make note of that
and i'm sitting in the comments section
i'm fighting for freedom
and i'm watching the news
dave
what our press was reporting
wasn't what was happening
and the only reason i knew that
because i fought in the battles they
were describing on television
so this sounded like blasphemy so when
walter cronkite you know the the grand
pupa of journalism
and that tonight here's a shapyash
evening news he said you're lying to us
and that's
you know dave that's when i went
we're being screwed and i realized this
book is in 1848 was coming true it's
only 50 pages
most people have never read it
so that's all right so you've given
you've given me a lot of avenues to go
there so first i love that you started
by connecting capitalism to freedom
because we seem to be losing both right
now so so to connect this a little bit
directly to capitalism at the moment
how do you think capitalism
uh or why do you think perhaps that
capitalism didn't sell itself well
enough
right now like like the sales people for
capitalism maybe are failing and that
seemingly is why the ideas of the book
that you keep holding up uh communist
manifesto for our audio listeners uh
seems to be taking off
well when i wrote rich dad poor dad
which came out in 1997 it was turned
down by every one of those marxist book
editors in new york unbelievable
unbelievable i know you're not talking
about they're all crumbling now so
you're you're getting your just rewards
and i asked them i asked the question in
1970
1997 i published a book so what did
school teach you about money
why not
see and and then that's when those
marxists
in new york city couldn't answer the
question they said well you don't know
what you're talking about
and i said what do you mean he says well
you talk about the rich not paying taxes
i said that's correct
so if if you understand taxes
taxes came in in 1913
with the creation of the federal reserve
bank
the fed is a central bank
doesn't that send chills up and down
your spine
so in 1913 it does now it does now it
maybe maybe didn't 10 years ago but i
was very different 10 years ago and dave
10 years ago
if you and i are having this
conversation
the little white men in the little the
rubber suit to be dragging me out the
door
so i said you know i mean
what did they teach you about money and
then go
nothing
has ever asked yourself why
well no because money is the level of
root the love of money is the root of
all evil you know some of that christian
stuff i'm going i'm not knocking
christians i'm just saying you know it's
a lot of religious indoctrination in
money
you know if you if you study money that
means you're going to be greedy evil and
be a
sex trafficker or something i'm going
man there's so much stuff attached to
this little subject called money
so capitalism to me is basically free
market capitalism it's freedom you want
to be a communist knock yourself out and
most teachers are communists they just
don't know it they don't understand that
taxes
but what mark said about a progressive
income tax is essential for the spread
of communism
you know it's right in the book read it
do you think that they don't
it's interesting because you're saying
they don't know that they're communists
but do you think they also fundamentally
don't seem to understand a certain part
of human psychology the way we actually
work what actually drives us the way we
want to maintain relationships that
there are win-wins in business things of
that nature
well i'll tell you what in my i didn't
do well in school you know i mean i went
i only reason i got into naval academy
and merch train academy
yes i played football and
i had high sats my grades were terrible
i just hated school i just hated it but
i got through it
but teachers live in a different world
as you know they have a different value
system it's not good or bad
so
in my family is the number of advanced
degrees you had made you superior to
those who didn't
so i used to say that my dad with a phd
poor dad
phd does that stand for poor helpless
and desperate
and naturally got my mouth washed out
with soap if you know what i mean
and my poor my rich dad never went to
school so he was trained as a small
business guy starting the age of 13. so
he
he'd seen like i said when i was in
vietnam what was reported on the news
didn't happen
you know i was in those battles i was at
quang tree way
uh fought in cameron you know outside of
cameron and all this
it was fake news exactly as trump says
and i did write this book here with
my friend donald trump
you've written two books with him right
yes yes great man you know
very good man i'll tell you a story
about him people wonder what he's like
there's no two donald trumps
[Laughter]
there's one guy and whoever's talking to
you at that moment is the real donald
trump
and i was he and i speak at these
massive real estate conventions
and one day i got up on stage with him
and i made the mistake of saying
uh there was a person leona helmsley
they call her the queen of maine oh yeah
i remember i'm from new york back then
yeah yeah all the new york post
headlines the daily news the whole thing
yeah yeah yeah yeah so leona gets up
there and called people little people
oh yeah i remember oh yeah so it was
massive yeah on stage
and i i've mentioned the word little
people trump came up on stage
and in front of maybe i don't know how
many thousands of people ten thousand
that was that job at center which is a
big place
he comes up there and he says in front
of everybody says never use the term
little people
you treat everybody with respect
that's who donald trump is now you never
guess that when he calls
little marco
[Laughter]
lying hillary and all this stuff
but he treats everybody around them with
respect
except when he's on stage and on twitter
was it was it purely both of your love
of capitalism that brought you guys
together i mean you're doing you're
speaking at these events and things but
like when you really sort of meshed and
thought okay i can write a book with
this guy
uh now i mean trump on our real estate
guys
real estate you know he's real estate
guys don't pay taxes i think you know
that
the rich don't pay taxes there's ways to
lose money that kind of work out
sometimes
and so when hillary when hillary said to
him and he doesn't pay taxes
what was his response i'm smart
smart
i said i agree
but remember tax is marks
a progressive income tax is essential
for the spread of communism
that came in in 1913 with the creation
of the federal reserve bank
so what else was created in 1913 which
you don't teach you in school was irs
so for there to be a central bank there
had to be tax
central banks are essential to communism
command and control economy everybody
knows that except if you went to school
you know it's interesting because i can
tell you as somebody that lived the last
eight years in california i now live in
in the free state of florida your your
facial reaction was just right um you
know now obviously i'm not paying any
income tax and it's like man you know
what this state is still running and
actually it's running quite efficiently
and freedom is flourishing and business
is flourishing and everyone's moving
here and i have two businesses here and
it's like everyone's fleeing california
because they're just taking 10 at the
end of the year what they're doing with
it nobody freaking knows
that's really tragic because you know i
i believe i left hawaii too
hawaii is more marxist than california
unfortunately good people nice weather
but they don't know they're marxists
they really don't because they didn't
they didn't teach the difference in
school but it's a feeling
do you know what i mean don't you feel
difficult yes
you're totally right i i literally feel
different i i'll tell you this i felt
when i was landing in the plane december
17 2021 landing in the plane when i
landed in florida i felt something lift
off my chest that's how oppressive i
felt that it was especially the last two
years in california yes i can't believe
what's happening dave
so i wrote rich dad poor dad back in
1997 i first created the cash flow board
game
to teach financial statements
income and expense adjustments of cash
flow
you know and and but most people they
leave school they have a high gpa grade
point average
but they don't have a financial
statement
strange isn't it
what's more important your grade point
average or your financial statement
and my rich dad always said to me
because he never went to school
because my poor dad was a phd you know
poor helpless desperate and my rich had
said
i'm like 12 years old he says my
banker's never asked me for my report
card yet
so i brought rich dad poor dad and now i
wrote this book here the capitalist
manifesto
because capitalism starts with a
financial statement think about it
how much income how many expenses assets
and liabilities and what most people
don't realize the us dollar is a
liability
against
the
the taxpayer
that's why 1913 the fed was created and
so was irs was that a mistake
probably
i think that would be an understatement
coming from you probably was i mean it
really is amazing that we don't teach in
public schools in the united states we
basically teach no financial literacy i
don't know if you've seen this but ron
desantis in florida just signed
something where they will start making
sure that you have basic financial
literacy and it's like oh okay we're
going to actually teach young people
something
rather than gender why'd you say that
because i'm kind of torn now between
trump and desantis you know
because trump and i are already always
for financial education and all this
stuff
but uh desantis is now going to start
using some of our things
to teach financial education in florida
so it's changing
but we're up against the teachers unions
and uh that's what this book manifesto
starts with
i'm not against teachers i'm against
stealing my freedom
and the first chapter is the nea
national extortion association the
teachers union the most powerful richest
teachers i mean most powerful union in
america are do you think maybe they're
losing some power now i mean after two
years of covet it seems like a lot of
people have maybe turned against them i
don't know whether it actually
translates into anything but people are
kind of fed up with it
well i think you and i you said it
earlier 10 years ago
we couldn't be saying what we're saying
now
10 years ago i couldn't have written
this book
but today you know when those communists
call uh
parents who question
you know critical race theory and sexual
orientation whatever they're doing
and they call any parent who questions
academics terrorists
i mean it's your kid
don't you have a right to say what you
teach your child
that and so that's why this the
manifesto book here is
how to combat communism taught in our
schools
by teaching capitalism in our schools i
mean at home at home i teach my rich dad
taught me to be a capitalist at home not
at school i want to ask you so because
you talk about your rich dad poor dad
obviously
do you think it was something beyond
just the education
that defined them in that regard like do
you think it was a personality trait or
um nature versus nurture that a certain
type of person becomes more interested
in relying on a system and a certain
type of person is wired to say hey i'm
going to go get mine beyond just the
education part well that's why i say phd
poor helpless desperate
they need the job they need the paycheck
they need the benefits
whereas when i went to the us marine
corps that's a different education
never taught the lead we're taught to
fight we talked to sacrifice you know
nicholson says it best in a few good men
santiago's death while tragic save lives
and you can't handle the truth
you can't handle that and that's the u.s
it's weird that he's now the good guy i
love them i mean i hated it when i was
in it those sobs they were yelling and
screaming at me 24 7.
but when we got to vietnam we were a
fighting machine
you know i flew the helicopter gunship
and my crew chiefs were just as
important as the pilots
you know we couldn't function
without a team
and we killed a lot of people
unfortunately
but we also had a lot of atrocities
against us too
and so when i realized i was in vietnam
for the second time when they're in 66
and then 72
and we're fighting for freedom that's
what we're fighting for not capitalism
that i come back on land at norton air
force base in california
january 10 1973
and i get spit on get hit by eggs by all
those hippies from the woodstock
generation
i saw
i saw this book which i read in 1965
coming true
i said we're going we're becoming a
communist nation
so what is the best way
i mean my audience watching this they
like capitalism and we can sell
capitalism on them all day they don't
even need it sold on them in a certain
regard but what is the best way to
deprogram someone out of the communist
manifesto because that seems to be where
we're at now with a whole generation of
young people
well that's a great question because i
learned to be a capitalist playing
monopoly
ain't that a hard day
especially if you're the one doing the
banking it's pretty easy
just just watch the banker's hands
exactly look over there okay okay
it's really sweet to be the government
but it's you know four green houses 1031
tax deferred exchange
i was watching that
and then people kept asking me
how did you know how did my wife
she was 37 i was 47 when we retired so
how'd you guys do it and we couldn't
explain it to them because most people
went to school they learned go to school
get a job work hard save money get out
of debt and invest for the long term in
the stock market i do none of that i
don't have to any of that
so anyway we created the cash flow board
game it's the onl because maria
montessori was one of the great
entrepreneur i mean educational
entrepreneurs yeah she says what the
hand does
the mind remembers now think about this
could you learn to play golf reading a
book
but that's what our schools are trying
to do so my wife and i in 1996
first created the cash flow board game
to teach the financial statement the
single most boring subject in schools
it's horrible so we made it fun we made
a game and all this so income expense
assets liabilities cash flow those are
three main financial statements in a
financial statement
income statement which is income expense
balance sheet asset liability and thirds
of statement of cash flow that's what
the game is called cash flow so i think
he hasn't agreed to it but the santees
is considering
using our board game to teach financial
education because kim's like kids like
to play with games i did yeah i hated
lecture i hated it
how cool are you going to get a little
uh you get a little residual on that or
what
of course you're a capitalist i mean
come on
make it what what what a deng peng singh
get rich is glorious i agree with him
he's a communist but i agree
it's not bad do you happen to remember
there was a game
back when i was a kid so this was on the
apple 2c before the mac mac or the
macbook or any of that there was a game
on apple 2c called lemonade stand and
that's what it was you were running a
little lame lemonade stand there were no
graphics it told you the weather and how
much sugar maybe you should buy and how
many people are out on the street and
and i learned a lot from that actually
yeah yeah we learned by doing
and so the cash flow board game rich dad
poor dad the only book that covered the
three financial statements income
statement
balance sheet
statement of cash flow
those are the three things that count
and so when i walk into my banker today
like in 2008 when the whole thing
collapsed with layman and by the way i
was on cnn speaking to wolf blitzer
saying lebanon was going down wow
you know so i called that one because i
could see you can see it coming you know
and so i was on lehman i called it
coming down and all this stuff
but it's just a matter
of teaching you know all we have to do
is teach
but the teachers unions are in the way
and my poor dad guess what he was head
of
teachers union
and if you study marx his words were
workers of the world unite
and my father
and my rich dad you know this i was like
15 or 16.
his workers were going out on strike in
hawaii
and rich dad called me says would you
mind coming to manage you know maintain
one of our desks for us
at night
so i said sure so i went down and helped
my uh rich dad out by may just be a kid
managing the death so tourists could
check in and out and i got home and my
poor dad gave me hell he says you're a
scab
wow
i was just helping a friend out but the
teachers union as you know they're as
marxists as they come
workers of the world unite so that's all
in that's all in capitalist manifesto
they're just quotes
they're just quotes from stalin marx mao
and all those guys
we were warned but nobody paid attention
so how do what do you think the first
step in reversing that is if if you were
talking to a 20 if there's a 21 year old
watching this show that's on the fence
maybe they just got out of school
although i know you would say they don't
have to go to school in the first place
but let's say they're 21 they're trying
to figure out what they're going to do
where they're going to live what kind of
life they want but they've been
indoctrinated with a certain amount of
that stuff what's the first way we can
get these people do you think i think i
think the first to do is question the
indoctrination
as thomas sol you know from stanford
says
it's not education it's indoctrination
go to school
what do you learn about money nothing
get a job who pays the highest taxes
workers
uh pay your taxes
rich don't pay taxes
get out of debt
i'm a billion dollars in debt because in
1971 when nixon took the dollar off the
gold standard i said thank you jesus i'm
going to borrow my ass off now
and invest in the stock market i don't
invest in the stock market i'm not
saying you shouldn't
but having a rich dad having financial
education understanding financial
statements understanding cash flow gave
me freedom that most people will never
have because they've been indoctrinated
go to school get a job work hard save
money pay taxes get out of debt and
invest in the stock market i don't do
any of those things because i don't have
to
do you think there's a unique moment for
people to follow your path right now
because so many people kind of don't
trust the system right now they see that
oh they can just print money money's
worth less none of this really makes
sense there are no balance sheets so
more people might be willing to do some
of the non-traditional things that
you've been doing for 30 years way more
than 30 years actually well i think you
said it earlier 10 years ago we couldn't
do this
that wasn't the zoom there wasn't any of
this you know this iphone here is the
most powerful entrepreneur tool ever saw
my whole life
i can text anybody in the world today
you know i can go on youtube but you got
your own podcast
it's so powerful
but if your brain isn't
a capitalist brain you use it
to watch kitty porn or whatever people
do today you know i mean it's like it's
did you it's also destroying our society
this iphone
that's my concern so that's why
you know i like trump and desantis and
i'm voting for financial education
because that's where capitalism begins
capitalism gives us more freedom and
that's all i fight for freedom
you know that when when kovit came out
they took away our freedom of speech
now they're going where our second
amendment the guns
disarm the police whatever they're
talking about defund the police it's all
marx
you know his mouth
says politics comes from the barrel of
the gun
it's all there it's it's in it's in this
book here it's all let me read you what
what nikita khrushchev said in 1959
your children's children will live under
communism you americans are so gullible
no you won't accept communism overnight
but we will keep feeding small doses of
socialism
until you'll finally wake up and find
out you already have communism that's
what we're finding out today that we
already are communists
we will not have to fight you
we will so weaken your economy until you
fall like over ripe fruit into our hands
nikita kusha september 29
1959 and i don't know yet jim records
just made an announcement
that the uh biden just signed into
executive order something
that cbdc central bank digital digital
currency were now 100 communists
biden just signed it on march 6 2022.
we're officially communist now because
they took control of our money central
bank digital currency
is a spy system it's spyware it'll
control our entire lives
so i would i would check out jim records
as a good friend of mine one of the
smartest guys i know
but today we must be cautious who our
sources of information are as you know
and jim records jim records is on the
pulse of it right now central bank
digital currency is 100 communists
so is that where do you think all of the
stuff of the last couple years has led
us that it was all going to lead us to
this central bank digital currency that
we'd be tracked and monitored and spied
on they could turn us on turn us off
decide who gets in the economy who
doesn't who gets certain privileges who
doesn't that that it was all leading to
this i mean this was conspir as you keep
saying 10 years ago we couldn't talk
about this five years ago we that was
pure conspiracy stuff right that's um
what the fight back you know i'm a u.s
marine not japanese marine
i i'm totally confident that you were on
the right side
i can't believe how stupid some
americans are
but but you don't have an american name
it's kiyosaki
but that's not american i said well
give me a break
i met this young woman she didn't know
who jfk was a high school graduate
i can't i mean
uh what is her education system doing
that's well i guess it's doing exactly
what the teachers union wanted it to do
huh
you said it the drone is circling your
house right now
they're always circling my house don't
worry
you know so so do what do you think the
answer i mean beyond okay so financial
literacy so we get some young people to
start paying attention to this stuff we
don't
feed the system the way that we've been
feeding the system um
maybe in florida we start you know doing
some financial literacy stuff but is th
has the ship sailed with the federal
government at this point i mean we're
we're in so deep
uh and money has been printed to such an
extent and as we're talking right now
inflation's 9.1 percent which that's
what they're telling us which probably
means it's more i mean what do you do
about all that if we're to have hope i'm
always trying to give my audience hope
well it is what this big word called
education is so please check out jim
records his latest thing on the cbdc
is exactly what i've been warning about
in this the central bank is
marxist
and the control of the currency is the
key
so now
now you build social credit scores and
all this you won't be able to do
anything and most americans are so
apathetic right now
you know well
so what
and that's why i always say to people
semper fi let's fight back
marines fight back
so that's why i'll back a candidate like
the santees or trump anybody who'll
fight but i've met some real wimps out
here oh my god
i mean they're
terrible we have to fight back we choose
our politicians wisely even stalin said
it's not who votes that counts
it's who counts it's who counts them i
mean
we've been warned about this stuff
are you surprised that so many
corporations went woke and went with
this communist ideology and everything
else because it we know it is hurting
their bottom line to an extent disney
lost something like 61 billion dollars
after fighting desantis uh we know that
all of these companies you know they put
all this product out there for for gay
pride month and nobody buys any of it or
for black pride what month and nobody
buys it but they put it out there they
have to be looking at the numbers at
some point but the ideology seems to
have superseded the whole purpose of
getting into business well that's one
way of fighting back is boycott
you know i mean i i'm very careful who i
buy from
and money talks as you know
but um
i i feel for the retailers right now
just
i go shopping and everything's on sale
why because in
because biden took the keystone xl
pipeline
destroyed it and then blames putin for
the high price of oil and i said i'm
qualified to speak on this
because as a graduate of the u.s merge
marine academy at kingsport new york my
major was oil i drove tankers for
standard oil i understand oil right
and why
you get wait are you getting that good
japanese a5 you must be you must be well
dave i hate to admit this but
i've always wanted to be a japanese
breeding bowl but i never got to be
there
so they live a good life
you think about it man all you do is as
a japanese breeding ball you sit there
and you have sex all day
my god that's it that sounds like
genka's con to me i want to do that
so
i am ah you're doing all right you're
doing all right i invest in waiku
breeding bowls
and they get you get paid for the semen
and the semen then goes into the cows i
own the cows also then i own the
offspring
that's cap
is this all in japan
is this all in japan wyoming oh it's in
wyoming so you can breed using
oh oh of course you can grow wagyu just
not not specific japanese wagyu right
that has to be from japan i don't know
all the specifics
it's called a brand
yeah and why why waiku
because rich guys eat waiku
poor people eat hamburger
okay or cat food
look
we get we'll begin to do in mass cat
food for everybody soon enough i think
i'm unapologetically a capitalist but i
want my freedom don't you touch my
freedoms
you know you want to eat hamburger knock
yourself out you want to eat cat food
knock yourself
out this uh this concept where no one
will own anything which seems to be one
of the other things they're talking
about right now this must make your
blood boil
well that's that guy what's his name uh
of clash schwab
i don't know who that character is but
my god
how can it that's pure marx
first thing that marx said was abolition
of private property
and what claude schwab says is someday
you'll own nothing and you'll be happy
and today look at the younger generation
you know the tick tock generation coming
up
they're completely clueless
yeah you know that's
when i talk to some of these young
people i don't know what the heck
they're watching or smoking
but there's
they're
they're so they're watching tick tock
yeah
while smoking various other things and
tick tock is a chinese invention
designed to mishmash our brains
yeah literally
literally so that's why i say this
little iphone here is the most powerful
tool ever created
we've got to be careful with it
so i'm pumping financial education
through it
but you can pump other things through it
too
so we need to fight back by being
selective on what we study what we eat
who we support who we buy from
because money does talk like it or not
i like it i have no problem with it uh
before we started the show i was talking
about the five g's with my guys can we
go through the five g's
of course i love the 5gs
i know i know take it away number one is
gold
gold is god's it's still worth something
gold is god's money he was placed here
with silver
when earth was formed you know people
say it's 5 000 years old no it's as old
as the earth gold and silver
own lots of gold and silver i own a gold
mine i just took a company public last
week new york stock exchange the richest
gold mine in the world
it's in
utah
140 year old mine we applied new
technology to it
and we found the richest veins in the
world
wow so gold is one
grub
waiku cattle
that's at the high level
i want you can eat hamburger or cat food
i'd rather have waiku
grub
ground real estate real estate is debt
financing
the reason i invest in real estate as
most people know this appreciation
depreciation amortization
all of those are tax dodges
so i said if i make a million dollars in
the in the income column
i need a bill i need a i need five
million in debt in the liability column
so by taking 1 million to 5 million
i step up my basis to 6 million i
depreciate it i pay no tax
that's why
and that that basically is what hillary
was angry at trump over because he knew
how to do it yeah because she's a she's
a thief
right right she just takes other
people's money for the non-profit she
wants to attack
but you know trump does it legally you
know she did that uranium one deal with
her husband
could not bill
so they steal
you know it's horrible so where was i
ground
gasoline oil
and then the third one guns fourth fifth
one is guns so i i'm fully armed all the
time you know i was i was just
i was just with mr shapiro he's armed
it's sad that we we're we have to be
this way
but i'm also marines i carry full
automatics
my rate of fire i step up the rate of
fire at my machine guns from about 700
rounds a minute to a thousand rounds per
minute
when i buy when i buy ammunition to buy
by the case i buy by the talent load
you're not messing around man no i'm
like you know al pacino and scarface
that's me my wife says that's you isn't
it he's up there going like this with
his guns going [ __ ] you [ __ ] you [ __ ]
you
that's me don't leave the uh
don't leave the fence open at the end
that's the key to the whole thing every
time i leave my house i make sure the
gate closes behind me yeah it's really
sad isn't it
it used to be you could trust everybody
now it's
anyway that's that's why i wrote rich
dead poor dead that's why i create the
cash flow game what the hand does the
mind remembers
and that's why i support people like
desantis and trump
because they're capitalists
we have to support capitalists
and we're
are you
do you consider yourself hopeful i mean
obviously you're you're concerned about
what's been going on for this last 90
years this march through the
institutions and everything but do you
consider yourself hopeful that we can
turn this around
well we have to do something
i mean it seems almost impossible right
now especially when
my friend jim records announced what
bite inside until law executive order
march 6 2022
it authorized cbdc central bank digital
currency which is surveillance that's
what every country in the world is doing
it now china is way ahead of us
so that's social credit scores and all
those other things they're gonna you
know i started with the little masks
which everybody knows doesn't work
or when i saw the doctors
speaking out against covet and they got
taken down
that's our freedom
so i don't care if you're a marxist or
this or a community or a capitalist
don't take my freedom away
and if i want to carry a gun
let me carry a gun don't disarm me
you know so that's kind of my
that's why i'm a us marine
i mean i fought for our freedom not for
capitalism
do you think we have better defenses
here in the u.s that sort of will be the
last stand where other countries you
know canada doesn't have the well they
certainly don't have the second
amendment but they don't even have the
defenses around speech i mean we still
have some firewalls left that a lot of
western nations don't have
well i think like i said this tools
little iphone here most powerful tool
but it's like a gun how do you use it to
defend yourself or kill somebody with it
and so that's why i'm honored to be on
your program i can't commend you you
have a lot of courage
and um you know i'm on patrick back
david and we're all speaking out
yeah but so are they speaking out
on the other side
this is what they used to to take down
trump into social media
he probably deserved
all the things he said
as a freedom of speech you know that's
all i care about
i have to fight back
i don't know when i'll lose but i won't
i'll go down fighting that's the
difference the u.s marine
you know that's the u.s military that's
most of our police officers so we better
fight back that's all i'm saying stand
up fight back
and it starts
when
i don't know who who landed them
terrorists but when the teachers
actually question the label terrorists
for questioning the teachers
that's what this book is about here is
it starts with the nea forbes called the
nea
not the next education association
national extortion association we spend
more on education than any country in
the world and when we get a kid who
doesn't know who jfk was
oh my god
you know i'm crazy what are we doing
robert you're going to be very proud of
me right now because not only am i a
capitalist but i've also started several
businesses and i started a tech company
called locals.com we've since merged
with rumble i'm sure you're aware of
rumble and we're going to finish up this
interview with two minutes exclusively
for my local subscribers because i am a
true capitalist how does that sound that
sounds fabulous if you're looking for
more honest and thoughtful conversations
about politics instead of non-stop
yelling check out our politics playlist
and if you want to watch full interviews
on a variety of topics watch our full
episode playlist all right over here and
to get notified of all future videos be
sure to subscribe and click the
notification bell